-The president is resisting
calls to release his tax returns
and calling the people
who investigate him traitors.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Before we get to Trump,
a bunch of other crazy stuff
happened today.
For example, you might remember
Michael Avenatti,
the guy who used to be
Stormy Daniels' lawyer.
Well, today, Avenatti was
charged with 36 counts of fraud,
perjury, failure to pay taxes,
embezzlement, and other
financial crimes.
And 36 counts is a lot.
But when you look at him,
you think,
"I thought it would have
been higher."
[ Laughter ]
And the details of the
indictment are truly insane.
"The L.A. Times" reports that
Avenatti stole
millions of dollars
from five clients.
He put $2.5 million
of that money
into the purchase
of a private jet.
And in the other case, the money
landed in the accounts
of GB Autosport, LLC,
which managed Avenatti's
racecar team.
How is this the first
we're hearing
of Michael Avenatti's
racecar team?
That's the dead giveaway
that someone is bad news.
The racecar track is where James
Bond meets the villain
for the first time as he's
pulling off his helmet
and his racing gloves.
[ As Bond villain ] Mr. Bond,
should we speak
somewhere quieter?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Also,
did you not see "Goodfellas"?
When you rip people off,
you gotta play it cool
with the money.
You're like a guy
who buys a Ferrari
and asks for the vanity plate --
"Bank Robber."
[ Laughter ]
While he was doing this,
Avenatti was actively
putting himself
in the spotlight.
He said he was going to run
for President in 2020.
He made more appearances on CNN
than the words "Breaking News."
And a lot of people
fell for Avenatti,
probably because his job
description was always
"attorney" and not
"racecar team owner!"
[ Laughter ]
While that was happening,
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
was also arrested in London,
where he was dragged out
of the Ecuadorian embassy
looking like Santa Claus
with a manifesto.
[ Laughter ]
"You're all naughty!
I have it on my list!"
[ Applause ]
I mean...
Based on that treatment,
I can't wait to read
what Assange writes on the
Ecuador embassy's Airbnb page.
[ Laughter ]
Now Ecuador had granted Assange
asylum in their embassy,
but withdrew it, which allowed
U.K. authorities to arrest him.
According to The Daily Beast,
Ecuador imposed a new
and detailed set of rules
on its fugitive guest,
banning unannounced visitors
and requiring Assange
to pay his own medical bills,
clean up after himself
in the bathroom,
and tend to the well-being,
food, cleanliness,
and proper care of his cat.
Assange bristled
at the restrictions,
and took Ecuador's foreign
ministry to court.
He took them to court
over his cat.
[ Laughter ]
Usually people go to court
to get restraining orders
against their cats.
"Please, your honor,
he keeps glaring at me
like he wants to kill me."
Now look, you can think Assange
is a creep, which he is,
and also be worried about what
this means for press freedom.
But one person who's always been
very clear
about where he stands on
WikiLeaks is Donald Trump.
And yet, when Trump was asked
today about WikiLeaks,
which he repeatedly praised
throughout the campaign,
he pretended he didn't know
anything about it.
-Mr. president, do you
still love WikiLeaks?
-I know nothing about WikiLeaks.
It's not my thing.
-Oh, it's not your thing?
Well, what is your thing?
-Who do you like in the Masters?
Who do you think will win?
-You know, there are 15 players
capable of winning,
and I guess you could say there
are a lot more than that.
They're great players. I don't
think a field for the Masters
has ever been this deep.
I was watching late last night,
and they were going over
the different players.
I think the field
has never been so deep.
But always Phil and Tiger
and...Dustin.
I mean, you have
so many great players.
But they were just saying,
they're younger,
they're stronger, they have
never hit the ball this long.
They have never hit the ball
this accurately.
They have never putted better
than they do now.
You know, the whole thing
is pretty incredible.
But the field is very,
very deep.
I think it's going to be
a great Masters.
-That's the most coherent answer
he's ever given.
[ Laughter ]
And it wasn't even
that coherent.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If being President was just
answering golf questions,
this guy would be George
Washington.
[ Laughter ]
But seriously, how can you say
WikiLeaks is not your thing?
Your government just arrested
a guy whose organization
you repeatedly praised
throughout the campaign,
and you're acting like someone
just offered you weed
at a party.
[ As Trump ] "Oh, no thanks,
man. That's not my thing."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Also, do you not remember
when you said all of this stuff?
-The sad part is we don't talk
about WikiLeaks.
Because it's incredible.
You see so much from
these WikiLeaks.
You see so much.
Boy, I love reading
those WikiLeaks.
I'll tell you, this WikiLeaks
stuff is unbelievable.
This WikiLeaks is like
a treasure trove.
WikiLeaks is amazing.
WikiLeaks! I love WikiLeaks.
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Trump ] I love WikiLeaks.
[ Normal voice ] He said it --
[ Cheers and applause ]
He said it like the guy
at the end of a rom-com
who can finally admit he's
in love with his best friend.
"I can finally say it,
I love Carol!"
[ Laughter ]
While Trump was dodging
questions about
his previous support
for WikiLeaks,
he was also dodging questions
about everything
from the Mueller Report
to his tax returns.
Last week, Democrats requested
six years of Trump's personal
and business tax information
from 2013 to 2018,
including individual tax returns
and returns from eight
businesses linked to Trump --
eight businesses.
Of course, it's hard to find
those returns
since seven of those businesses
went bankrupt years ago.
if you want to find the tax
returns for Trump Steaks
or Trump Vodka, you have to go
deep into the IRS basement
and look in the box labeled
"obvious scams."
[ Laughter ]
But the law is clear.
Democrats on the house
Ways and Means Committee
have the power to request
Trump's tax returns.
And yet Trump told reporters
yesterday
he would just flat out ignore
the request
using the same obviously false
excuse he's been using
since 2016 -- he's under audit.
And towards the end
of his rambling answer,
he found a way to start bragging
about his businesses.
-While I'm under audit,
I won't do it.
If I'm not under audit,
I would do it.
I had no problem with it.
But while I'm under audit,
I would not give my taxes.
There's no law whatsoever.
Now, I will say this --
I would love to give them,
but I'm not going to do it
while I'm under audit.
What I have done is
approximately
a 104-page summary,
and really in great detail,
of assets and values
and -- Nobody wants to go over
that because it's so good.
I built a great company,
one of the best companies.
I have some of the greatest
assets in the world.
I did a good job.
-Well, now he's just doing
affirmations in public.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] "I did a good job.
I'm good at business.
My wife does like me."
[ Normal voice ] Also,
can you please just drop
this dumb audit excuse?
It's obviously fake. You've been
saying it since 2016.
There's no way it's taking
the IRS three years
to go through your tax returns.
And if it has, that doesn't
make you look great.
If you told someone it took you
a week to clean your kitchen,
they'd be like, "How [bleep] up
was your kitchen?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
While Trump is just ignoring
the law on his tax returns,
he's also sounding increasingly
unhinged
on the Russia investigation.
Now because Trump keeps lying
about it,
we have to just take
a step back here
and remember how all of this
got started.
Russia hacked
the Democrats' e-mails
while they were doing
business deals with Trump
and making contact with
Trump campaign officials.
And the entire time these people
were lying about it.
And then when the FBI started
investigating it,
Trump asked the director
to shut it down
and pledge his loyalty to Trump.
And when he refused,
Trump fired him.
And then he said on TV
he fired him
because of the Russia
investigation.
He told the Russians
he fired him
because of
the Russia investigation.
And then because his Republican
Attorney General had recused
himself, his Republican Deputy
Attorney General appointed
a special counsel, Robert
Mueller,
who is a registered Republican.
And, while this was happening,
Putin also gave Trump
a soccer ball.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Which was definitely,
definitely the first time Trump
ever saw a soccer ball.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Thank you for
this beautiful gift.
I'm going to say
a Russian bowling ball?
[ Laughter ]
And it probably has,
when you open it,
a littler bowling ball in it?
And then another little one
and a then little one?
[ Applause ]
And hopefully at the end,
a tiny marshmallow?
[ Normal voice ] I wish
I didn't have to keep recapping
all this stuff every time
we talk about it.
I'm starting to think we're
just gonna need
a permanent scroll that stays up
throughout the show.
But I have to keep recapping it
because Trump keeps
lying about it.
Yesterday, his Attorney General
repeated
Trump's conspiracy theory that
his campaign was spied on.
And then Trump suggested
the investigation
was somehow illegal
or unwarranted,
and even said the people
investigating him were traitors.
-It was an illegal
investigation.
It was started illegally.
Everything about it was crooked,
every single thing about it.
There were dirty cops.
These were bad people.
And this was an attempted coup.
This was an attempted takedown
of a president.
This was an illegal witch hunt,
and everybody knew it.
And they knew it, too.
And they got caught.
And what they did was treason.
-My God, man.
Now you're accusing people
of coups and treason.
I'd say you should start
growing a dictator beard,
but based on your actual hair,
I'm not sure how
that would look.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is why it's crucial
that decisions
involving the Mueller report
remain independent of Trump.
And yet yesterday, when his
Attorney General William Barr
was asked if he briefed
the White House
on the Mueller report,
Barr's answer was very evasive.
-Has anyone in the White House
seen any of the report?
-You know, I'm not gonna --
I'm not gonna -- as I said,
I'm landing the plane right now.
And, uh, you know, I've been
willing to discuss my --
my letters and the process
going forward.
But the report is going to be
out next week.
And I'm just not going to get
into the details
of the process until
the plane is on the ground.
-The plane has been
on the ground.
Mueller landed the plane.
You're the crew guy refusing
to drive the little gate thingy
up to the door...
[ Laughter ]
...so we can get off the plane.
This is why --
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is why we need
aggressive oversight
of the Trump administration,
whether it's on the Mueller
report or his tax returns.
And yet Republicans
are doing the opposite.
They are protecting him.
For example,
after the Democratic chairman
of the house Ways and Means
Committee, Richard Neal,
submitted his formal request to
the IRS for Trump's tax returns,
Louisiana Senator John Kennedy
went on TV and straight up
called Neal a moron.
-Chairman Neal, powerful man,
head of Ways and Means.
I know he's an adult,
but I don't think he's
like a real adult.
[ Laughter ]
He says that he needs
Trump's tax returns.
He says it's policy,
not politics.
He has said, I think on CNN,
that the reason he needs them
is that he needs to determine
how well the IRS
is auditing taxpayers.
I can't believe he really thinks
the American people
are gonna fall for that.
It must really suck
to be that dumb.
[ Laughter ]
-It doesn't suck to be
that dumb.
It sucks for your boss
to be that dumb.
That's the guy you answer to.
Maybe think about
where your life is at.
You're a United States Senator,
and you take marching orders
from a guy who
once got on Air Force One with
toilet paper stuck to his shoe.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans in Congress
keep trying to defend Trump
from Democrats, but their
efforts keep falling flat.
And the dumbest example of that
came this week
during a hearing
on Trump's climate policies.
Democrats called former
Secretary of State John Kerry
as a witness,
and during the hearing,
Republican Congressman
Thomas Massie from Kentucky
tried to question
Kerry's credentials,
specifically his college degree.
Kerry has a Bachelor of Arts
in Political Science,
a common degree that
lots of people have.
And yet Massie thought it was
some kind of brilliant "Gotcha!"
to point that out,
resulting in one of the dumbest
lines of questioning
in the history of American
politics.
-It sounds like you're
questioning the credentials
of the president's advisers
currently.
But I don't think we should
question your credentials today.
Isn't it true you have
a science degree from Yale?
What's that?
-Bachelor of Arts degree.
-Is it a political science
degree?
-Yes, political science.
-So how do you get a bachelor
of arts in a science?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's a liberal arts
education and degree.
It's a bachelor.
-Okay,
so it's not really science.
So I think it's somewhat
appropriate that somebody
with a pseudoscience degree
is here pushing pseudoscience
in front of our committee today.
-[ Scoffs ]
I want to ask you --
-Are you serious?
I mean, this is really
a serious happening here?
-Yeah. It is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Unfortunately...
I'm sorry to say it is
a serious happening.
And that is the perfect
phrasing.
Because this whole Trump era
feels like a horror movie
called "A Serious Happening."
[ Laughter ]
This is an actual
member of Congress
who can't wrap his heard
around the fact
that you can get a bachelor
of arts degree
in political science,
despite the fact that he himself
has a degree from MIT!
I mean, why stop there, Massie?
[ As Massie ] "Senator Kerry,
you're a married man, correct?
Then please explain to us
how you could possibly have
a bachelor's degree."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Also, not
that anything matters anymore,
but that's the same John Kerry
who was falsely criticized
by conservatives
not for avoiding Vietnam,
but for going and supposedly
doing a bad job.
Meanwhile these same
conservatives now heap praise
on Lieutenant Bone Spurs
over here,
whose only Purple Heart is
the one struggling to get air
through his gravy-clogged veins.
Again nothing matters!
Because these are the people
protecting the president
in Congress.
The president refuses to release
his tax returns
and calls anyone who
investigates him treasonous,
and Republicans actually expect
us to believe
that they're the party
of the Constitution
and the rule of law.
I don't know if anyone
still believes that.
But if they do...
-It must really suck
to be that dumb.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪